hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
neuen Episode goat Simulator 3 mit mir
Luca und der Ziege allerdings heute auch
mit einem Gast denn ich werde heute zum
allerersten Mal den Multiplayer Modus
also dem Mehrspielermodus an und euch
die kein Englisch kann hallo in goat
Simulator 3 erkunden und die fragt euch
wahrscheinlich schon Luca warum läufst
du dafür jetzt rückwärts hier irgendwie
ein Berg hoch bis die ganze Zeit einfach
daran weil ihr sonst schon sehen würdet
wer denn heute mit dabei ist der davon
macht Liegestütze ja sehr gut ihr würdet
jetzt gleich schon direkt sehen wer
dabei ist denn man sieht irgendwie den
Namen angezeigt durch Häuser keine
Ahnung was das soll von da könnt ihr
euch jetzt gerade noch kurz in den Po
angucken von der Ziege ich weiß nicht so
richtig wo ich Langlaufen muss ich die
Person befindet allerdings ist das Max
schon gezeigt dass man tatsächlich so
Emotes machen kann das wusste ich gar
nicht man kann vor gedrückt halten dann
kann man sich so hinsetzen
diesem Spiel guck mal er will auch eine
Ziege sein glaube ich ne ja aber
irgendwie so eine Fake Ziege
drei zwei eins
oh oh Entschuldigung
[Musik]
ich bin gegen Gewalt hier
das ist getroffen ich kann nicht dich
getroffen haben ich habe doch die Typen
geschossen ja oh Entschuldigung komm
doch mit ich weck mich jetzt an hier
kommt wir müssen tatsächlich wissen was
erreichen heute denn ich habe schon in
meiner letzten Folge gods mit gesagt
dass ich auf jeden Fall das Ende der Map
entdecken möchte wir haben AUA perfekt
falsch gemacht oder so können wir können
auch beschleunigen hier ja wir fliegen
ich weiß nicht sag mal hast du gerade
gelenkt nee ich kann nicht denken ich
glaube ja perfekt super ja wir fliegen
ja ich glaube ja denn
och ist ne
die sind groß
cool
oh oh ich habe gar kein Ziel für das
heutige Video was ist das hier
willkommen bei requisitenjagd versteck
dich lecker an einem Objekt um dich
darin zu verstecken ich muss
dich finden
du bist versteckt okay okay warte kannst
dich auch an andere Sachen verwandeln ja
ja echt jetzt okay ja das ist irgendwie
so hide and seek mäßig so ein bisschen
die ganze Zeit Punkte tatsächlich je
länger ich versteckt bin ja ich mache
alles kaputt einfach ja okay sehr gut
siehst du mich ich sehe dich ja nee dich
nicht
nee nee nee ich weiß aber gar nicht wie
du mich jetzt irgendwie finden sollst
ich weiß nicht aber ich suche einfach
alles ab ich kriege auf jeden Fall mehr
Punkte wenn ich mich bewege merke ich
gerade
vorbei ich war so ein Tisch guck mal ich
habe 71 Teile jetzt muss ich dich finden
eine Runde zwei oder muss ich mich
wieder verstecken
und jetzt sehe ich gar nichts ach lol
also du hast dich jetzt versteckt oder
was
okay und wie
kann ich
da irgendwie
[Musik]
drücken oder oder was
ich habe gerade bei dir weg du läufst ja
ich laufe
wo bist du denn
also ich dachte du wirst mich niemals
finden
ich bin gerade so links von der Statue
nee nee nee nee
du hast gewonnen ja
okay das Minispiel war jetzt nicht so
meins mitnehmen
ja sehr gut sieht so knuffig aus
dieses Spiel ne das ist mein Pokal Ciao
ich habe gegessen du musst mich jetzt
catchen okay ich kenn dich oh ich bin
voll auf die Fresse geflogen oh nein ich
habe noch den Pokal
kannst du mir den überhaupt abnehmen
wenn ich den lecker gerade schon okay
nein ich bin Beifahrer ich bin Fahrer
ich habe nein der Pokal
[Musik]
hä wo ist der Pokal nein da
nein
tschüss verpiss Dich ja Freunde ehrlich
gesagt haben
uns beide gar nicht überlegt was heutige
Video von daher hoffen wir es gefällt
Euch wie wir einfach gar nichts machen
hier vorne haben wir noch eine Trommel
entdeckt jetzt habe ich eine Trommel an
wundervoll was ist das hier oben das ist
ein Festival irgendwie gibt's voll viele
so Bühnen und sowas alles ne was ist das
hier keine Ahnung was das jetzt wieder
für ein Spiel ist
bleibe in dem Bereich um Kronen zu
gewinnen aber was heißt denn das jetzt
hier müssen wir
müssen gegeneinander kämpfen ach lol
Tschüß
hä und jetzt bleiben wir hier drin
einfach oder was ja wir müssen drinne
bleiben einfach ja dann länger drinne
bleibt gewinnen
Leute du führst schon wieder
aber ich bin dringend
nein ich wollte hoch springen
hier ne
ah nein
ich habe schon wieder verloren ich bin
der schlechteste goat Simulator Spieler
der Welt yeah hier mein Po
vom rutschen nein nein komm komm komm
schnell
nein oh nein oh nein
ich bin so ein Meter weit fahr mich
irgendwohin ich fahr dich jetzt zu
mir
zu dir nach Hause
okay da bin ich gespannt
das ganz klassisch
rein okay perfekt
[Musik]
super dann rechts dann links ja und hier
sind wir hier wohnst du hier rechts ja
das ist deine Villa
ja wer ist das hier mein Vater
ich kann die Anzeigen wegen Hausfrauen
[Musik]
kannst du diese ganzen Sachen
gespielt oder so ich habe mehr gespielt
aber ich kann das nicht steigen denn
drin
[Musik]
ich wohne hier
deswegen ja hier ist mein Haus
aha sag mal kackst du die ganze Zeit
oder was ist das hier ja
das ist tatsächlich mein Vater versucht
einzupacken
okay ja der braucht mal ein bisschen
aber gib dem Zeit komm
das kann sich nur noch um Tage handeln
alles gut
[Musik]
ja
ja sonst alles gut ich glaube aber der
hat es wirklich gleich ja ich würde an
der Stelle diese heutige Episode
Simulator mein erstes Mal Multiplayer
jetzt auch beenden meine lieben Freunde
ich habe heute mit mexify gespielt wenn
es euch gefallen hat das gerne einen
Daumen hoch unter diesem Video hier da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke weitere Videos nichts
verpassen kannst du aufhören mein Vater
da abzuwerfen